it's been an extraordinary last few days
in Russia that attempted Rebellion on
Saturday and then the rumors and the
claims that have followed all as
President Putin tries to reassert his
diminished Authority
well meanwhile in Ukraine the war grinds
on with the Ukrainian counter-offensive
seemingly getting into its stride
President zielinski says that progress
is being made and British Military
Intelligence assessments earlier this
week said the ukrainians had likely
taken ground held by Russia since 2014
the first time that's happened well
Canada is a key part of the Western
Alliance supplying arms and other AIDS
Ukraine the country's defense minister
Anita Anand is in the UK meeting our
defense secretary Ben Wallace I spoke to
her a little earlier
you've been here in the UK today talking
about Ukraine and what's been discussed
the continuing need for us to support
Ukraine in the short and the long term
as it fights back the Russians we've
seen Ukraine make gains in the North and
the East and the South and we as a group
of countries around the NATO table will
continue to be there to support Ukraine
it's about Ukraine sovereignty but also
the rules-based international order that
has kept us all safe since the end of
the second world war do you think that
Ukraine can actually win the war most
definitely
the resolve of the Ukrainian people is
evident Putin thought he would take Kiev
in days and he thought that Europe would
freeze in the dark he thought that the
NATO table would fracture all of those
things have not come to pass Ukraine is
continuing to show that it has the will
and the ability to win this unjust and
illegal War we had the extraordinary
week that we saw in Russia with the
attempted Rebellion by the head of the
Wagner group
has that made any difference do you
think to the war I told my team that we
need to continue to focus on the purpose
of Western and indeed Canadian Aid and
that is to help Ukraine fight and win
this war Canada has already donated over
1 billion dollars of military aid and
over 8 billion dollars of economic
financial and military aid overall and
that's our purpose focusing on how we
can help Ukraine we have a very large
Ukrainian diaspora in Canada and we are
100 with Ukraine so that it can win this
war you say you're 100 with Ukraine how
committed is Canada to Nato
Canada is a founding member of NATO and
we have been a strong partner around the
table we lead the enhanced forward
presence battle group in Latvia for
example and have done so for over five
years so we are very strong and
continuing contributing partner to Nato
with boots on the ground I guess one of
the reasons that I'm asking is because
NATO recently held its largest ever
combat exercise over Germany
Canada didn't go are you committed to
Nato or are you really prepared for
other people I guess to do your dirty
work for you not at all we have
participated in numerous NATO exercises
we recently signed a contract with
Lockheed Martin to purchase 88 f-35s and
we are in a period of growth in our
Royal Canadian Air Force and we are
continuing to undertake that growth
while participating in exercises
wherever we can
um you spent the day with Ben Wallace
the UK defense secretary today he was
hoping to get a new job head of NATO
would have you would you like to say
that Ben has been an incredible
collaborator and partner around the NATO
table as well as with the defense
contact group I enjoy working with him
immensely and will continue to do so
would you made a good at night overhead
then Ben's an incredible leader and I
know that he is very capable at whatever
he does
um
I'm Keen to ask you a bit of a big
picture question now because you know
it's great to have you here we don't
always get the chance to speak to
representatives from other countries in
this way
um we've been talking about Russia and
Ukraine but there are clearly other
Global threats that people have their
eye on for you what would you say is the
biggest Global threat right now
I think that it is a mistake for us to
focus on one conflict Zone alone and
indeed Putin would like nothing more
than to see us all Focus 100 on one
country the country that he illegally
invaded no for us we take a step back
and we say that the global threat
environment has changed overall Canada
recently released for example its
indo-pacific strategy we are committing
as a Pacific country to increase our
presence in the indo-pacific to add a
third frigate to engage in exercises
with our partners to increase our
presence in the area of cyber security
this is just an example of how Canada
won't just focus on one global conflict
Zone we will take a broad-based approach
to ensure that we are fulfilling our
obligations upholding internet national
law as well as International Norms it's
interesting you're talking about cyber
security
a lot of people talk about artificial
intelligence as being a way that is
Transforming Our World is that something
that you got your eye on as well Canada
is a leader in the artificial
intelligence space in the area of
quantum Technologies and Innovation writ
large and we certainly do have our eye
on that in furthering our relationships
with our partners offering our expertise
certainly in the five eyes context we
will continue to collaborate with our
partners in that Alliance as well as
around the NATO and NORAD tables and one
very different subject I want to ask you
about because I know that it's something
that many of our viewers have been
following very closely which is the fate
of the Ocean Gate submarine where people
tragically lost their loans when they
were going to try and view the Titanic
now Canadian authorities have been
investigating is there any update you
can give us on that well first and
foremost I'd like to extend my deepest
condolences to the families who lost
loved ones
in that incident my heart really goes
out to them in terms of Canada we have
an investigation that is ongoing that is
being conducted by Transport Canada and
right from the very beginning of the
search we had deployed an aircraft as
well as a Navy vessel to ensure that
Canada was doing whatever it could
together with the United States and
others to assist in the time of need but
of course that investigation is ongoing
of course the investigation goes on and
how important is it to try and get to
the bottom of what happened I guess to
either find out if there's anyone or
anything to blame and also to stop it
happening again of course as the
investigation proceeds it would be
premature for me to make those types of
comments or hypotheses but I will say
that Canada from a domestic standpoint
will always be there to assist when
others have needs whether it is
domestically as we fight forest fires at
home or whether it is internationally
and collaborating with our allies in the
evacuation of Sudan or anywhere else and
that's exactly what we're seeing around
the aid for Ukraine and one of the
things I'm going to be doing tomorrow is
visiting Camp lid where Canadian Armed
Forces members together with other
countries including the UK are training
Ukrainian new recruits that's the type
of collaboration that Canada will bring
to the table regardless of the issue
okay thank you thank you so much